in the heart of power a show of
solidarity with the people of ukraine as
russia's hope for a lightning war gives
way to a slow protracted battle
we are all on a war footing now
the cabinet convening again today the
government offering more military
support and supplies but what about
waiving visas as well as flags for
refugees
today announced some relaxations for
family members of ukrainians already
here but refusing to offer any ukrainian
temporary refuge on british shores i've
seen members of this house calling for
full visa waivers for all ukrainians
security and biometric checks are a
fundamental part of our diesel approval
process worldwide and will continue that
is vital to keep british citizens safe
and to ensure that we are helping those
in genuine need
mps across the house demanding a more
humanitarian approach
the russian invasion began
five days ago other countries responded
with clear sanctuary arrangements
immediately we've had a weekend of
complete confusion we still don't know
what the arrangements are
why is nothing worked out already and
how on earth is the home secretary so
poorly prepared
this form of justice secretary wants the
government to issue temporary visas for
those fleeing war what do you actually
want them to do in in concrete terms at
times of war an extraordinary challenge
requires an extraordinary response and
that's why i think that it is important
that orbit on a temporary basis with the
sort of safeguards that we want to see
in
in place i believe that the british
public would support and do support the
tradition of compassion
it's that compassion that andre wants
for his family all in ukraine here
celebrating the turn of the new year in
kiev just weeks ago
but now his mother hides in a bomb rage
shelter his father has taken up arms on
the front line and his 19 year old
sister anne-marie has fled to the
romanian border desperate to seek refuge
in the uk so i have enough funds to
sustain my sister and it's not that she
will
be a refugee and then the uk economy
will have to pay for her being here i
can do it myself i just want to get you
to be close to me and be safe here
and as the situation in ukraine darkens
the protests and the pressure at home
will only grow
ministers won't scrap security checks
but they are planning to expand the
current family scheme to let more
refugees in bathrood b sky news
westminster